[Music]
[Applause]
in february
nasa's perseverance rover landed on mars
where the one-ton rover has begun its
search for past life
[Applause]
the purpose of the perseverance
expedition
on mars is to gather
signs of life that may have existed
there
early in the evolution of the planet
and if it can find any of those life
signs any bio signatures
pack them up cache them in very special
sterile tubes for retrieval
and return to earth nasa is currently
running detailed tests and calibrations
on the rover
during an initial evaluation period so
as we speak
they are still checking out all the
onboard engineering systems on the
perseverance rover it's a robotic arm
it's a camera mass they're testing out
the
heaters make sure it doesn't uh freeze
during the extremely cold martian nights
it will probably take another few weeks
to check out all these onboard
engineering systems
and then later this month they will
start looking around
jezreel crater and they are
seeking a nice flat
unobstructed site that could serve as
the first
helipad on mars the perseverance landing
marks nasa's fifth successful trip to
the red planet
its predecessors spirit opportunity and
sojourner all completed their missions
before losing contact
the curiosity rover which landed in 2012
is still operational
this is the first time we've ever gone
looking for something that we're going
to bring back to earth
that is really cool and one of the
reasons it's cool is because mars used
to be a lot like earth
and we don't understand yet why mars
doesn't look like earth anymore
jennifer trosper is the deputy project
manager at nasa's jet propulsion
laboratory in california better known as
jpl
she's been working on the perseverance
missions for eight years
i can tell you that perseverance is
operating
perfectly right now that all systems are
go
we're getting all kinds of data and lots
of images
i think the the amount of data
throughput we've had
has been phenomenal the um the early
images i think in terms of how much
we've been able to get down and just
look at
has been great and that whole data flow
has really kind of taxed our
infrastructure in a way that we're um
we're getting better at that but that
early on um caused us some snafus i felt
like the building was shaking there was
so much data coming in
it's like we just aren't used to this we
have to figure out how to manage it and
uh and so it's getting better but yeah
it's a lot of data to manage
last week the rover drove for the first
time on the martian landscape
and perseverance has already been back
over 8 000 photos capturing the craggy
terrain
and rocks and dunes the next thing we're
trying to do is get ready for the
helicopter mission in order to get ready
for the helicopter mission
we have to get the arm and the camera on
the arm
operational and so we'll be spending
about the next week doing that
i would say by by early april the
helicopter
early to mid april the helicopter should
be there ready to start its mission
i think you know kind of late summer is
when i
everything including the helicopter
mission is kind of
ready to go for going towards getting
those samples that we want to bring back
to earth those samples could help answer
one of the fundamental mysteries of the
universe
it's the culmination of 50 years
of exploration of mars and liftoff
as the countdown to mars continues this
is all designed to answer
a question that has really haunted
humankind
since we first started turning our eyes
skyward and looking at the stars
are we alone is there life
anywhere in the cosmos perseverance
if all goes as nasa hopes will offer
us the first concrete opportunity
to answer that question definitively